voters in Spain go to the polls on
Sunday to choose a new Parliament
campaigning has ended with some polls
suggesting a swing to the right the
country is run by a center-left
government at the moment but it could
end up with a coalition that includes a
far-right party after this election
Spain hasn't had a nationalist party
since the death of military leader
Francisco Franco back in 1975.
come on for more on this let's speak to
our correspondent on the ground there in
Madrid Sonia Gallego Sonya as we've been
saying summer holidays there how do
people feel about having had this snap
election called now
Well there's almost a sense of of
weariness I suppose of having had this
event to really Clash into the main
Spanish holidays here and of course that
is because the Prime Minister Pedro
Sanchez called the snap elections after
uh his party's poor performance in the
local elections at the end of May but
one point of interest to note here is
the fact that it has really galvanized
postal voting here some 2.6 million
people at least have signed up to vote
at post offices that could be something
which favors the Socialists as more
people who are galvanized to vote in
here are we'll take those votes and as
how they can possibly do so so with that
in mind though it's quite a lot of
support that Mr Sanchez is still lacking
if he's going to successfully beat off
the opposition and that is the people's
party uh who he's still been trailing
behind in the polls
it's the fight of his political life
Pedro Sanchez ended his party's campaign
by urging his supporters to keep the
faith
we've done the best campaign the best we
fell down we got up again we ran against
the clock and sprinted and climbed to
unimaginable highs and where only a few
meters from reaching our final goal
it's been a hotly contested race in
socialist not a straightforward path
bite a steady economic recovery it has
not powered Sanchez on a path to clear
victory
May's local elections saw huge losses
for the Socialist and major wins for the
People's Party even in traditional
left-wing working-class neighborhoods
like vallecas which has been
increasingly turning away from its
socialist roots
poverty is an issue here many who live
here often complain of feeling
discriminated against left behind
without essential Services as other
areas are modernized
we need more help and the person who
will take care of us is the person we
will vote for
people are so tired this is a
working-class neighborhood and here
they're Fed Up of the injustices and
they will make decisions based on that
the leader of the conservative People's
Party Alberta
and lower spending
the change will be for the better to
have a good government to have a better
government and better politics
observative vision of the people's party
does not go far enough and it's where
the far-right Vox party has found a
following
once a People's Party politician in The
Basque Country its leader Santiago
abascal with his unequivocally
anti-immigration nationalistic platform
has found enough support to turn his
party into the third largest political
force in the country
and a potential Coalition partner
this would be the first time since the
restoration of democracy in the late
1970s that Spain would have a far right
presence in its government and further
consolidate a growing hard right
presence within the European Union Sonia
Gallego Al Jazeera Madrid
now Vox of course is a relative newcomer
to the Spanish political scene
nevertheless they're already proving
themselves to be disruptors to that
traditional two-party system there and
have even been going into deals with the
People's Party in Regional uh
governments as well and in region and
councils as to nevertheless vox's
rhetoric around immigration and Regional
separatism as well we'll put it on a
collision course with those separatist
movements not just in the Basque country
but Catalonia as well oh Sonia you
yourself were in Catalonia just in the
last couple of days reporting on what
might happen how is this being viewed
there are we expecting a good turnout do
people feel invested in this election
well I they do actually feel invested in
the sense that the momentum is with the
People's Party at the moment judging by
the polls and judging by the turnout of
those local elections uh the leader
Alberto certainly seems like as if the
momentum lies with him the question is
how much of a majority he can actually
pull off if he fails to get a majority
which means that he his party can have
absolute a majority in Parliament then
that would be uh considered an enormous
success for him however if he doesn't
reach that limit he will have to
consider a deal with a Vox party and
that of course has uh quite a lot of of
effects there not least of all uh how uh
it's going to affect policies in the
country as well and this is something
that the left and the
parties as well have been warning about
saying if you don't want that then
you're going to have to vote for the
left or for us Sonia Gallego there with
all the latest forests from Madrid we'll
stay across that election for you here
on Al Jazeera thank you for now Sonia